Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich hab überlegt, eine Podcast-Steuer zu erheben, sowohl für das Senden als auch für das Empfang.
Und was willst du jetzt von mir?
Weiß ich nicht, du kannst mir deine wiederrufliche gratis Einwilligung dafür geben. Logbuch, Netzpolitik, nicht nur die 120. Ausgabe, sondern auch endlich mal wieder eine mit Linus. Hallo.
Ja, hallo. Und wieder eine aus der Ferne.
Und wieder eine aus der Ferne. Und nicht ganz unerheblich, in der Zwischenzeit ist ja dann auch unser drittes Jubiläum ungenutzt verstrichen.
Der dritte Geburtstag, ja, immer noch nix. Ich wünsche mir jedes Jahr ein Fest.
Ja, dann müsste ich wohl mal aktiv werden, meinst du.
Ja, ich mach das nicht.
Ja, vielleicht kriegen wir ja noch was hin.
Oder die Hörerinnen könnten ja auch mal was Schönes, eine schöne Überraschungsparty bei mir zu Hause oder so.
Genau, wir treffen uns einfach alle bei dir zu Hause. Das ist doch super. Du füllst schon mal den Kühlschrank.
Das habe ich einmal gemacht, dass ich ein bisschen zu viele Leute eingeladen habe. Da waren dann einige Nachbarn nicht so begeistert von. Ich meine, als ich alle Möbel aus der Wohnung rausgeräumt hatte, was lassen wir das?
Das kann ja hier nicht weiter schlimm sein, weil du weißt ja, Podcasts sind ja Nischen und die kommen ja aus ihrer Nische auch nicht raus. Also da kann ja dann eigentlich auch keiner aufhauen.
Hört keiner, geht keiner hin, interessiert keinen.
So sieht es aus.
Deswegen haben wir auch kein Leistungsschutzrecht.
Genau, das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Das interessiert nämlich auch keinen. Das ist irgendwie wirklich so dieses Gefühl, da steht jemand auf der Wiese und fordert irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, pinkfarbene Bahnautomaten und keiner hat dem zu. Was passiert? Einiges.
Also die Verlage, die in der VG Media organisierten Verlage hatten ja irgendwie ein großes Bohai gemacht. Wir erinnern uns, die wollten gerne von Google Leistungsschutzgeld bekommen, weil Google ja auf ihre Inhalte verlinkt und dazu für diese Links kleine Anreißer-Texte aus ihren Artikeln nimmt, um den Leuten richtig den Mund wässrig zu machen, damit die den Link auch klicken. Und dann hat Google ja irgendwann gesagt, naja, okay, wenn ihr aber jetzt hier mit eurem Leistungsschutzrecht und so kommt, dann folgen wir mal dem Wortlot des Gesetzes und lassen bei euch dann die Bilder und die Anreißer-Texte weg, weil das dürfen wir ja nicht, wenn ohne eure Erlaubnis. Und dann haben die in der VG-Media organisierten Verlage gesagt, ja, okay, dann holt sie euch doch mal. Dann haben sie ja erst noch gesagt, nee, ihr nutzt eure Marktmacht aus, wir rufen das Kartellamt an und das Kartellamt hat gesagt, meine Güte, jetzt könnt ihr uns nicht bitte endlich in Ruhe lassen. Und dann drohte also jetzt, die Links zu diesen Verlagen nur noch mit dem Artikel-Titel verlinkt zu werden bei Google News und dann haben sie, ich glaube, ein paar Tage bevor das dann in Kraft treten würde, eine widerrufliche Gratis-Einwilligung erteilt.
Also vorher ging es ja irgendwie auch noch so total hin und her. Ja, es gab ja so verschiedene Artikel, die auch so ein bisschen Gerüchtekücheverarbeitung zu sein schienen, auf der einen Seite so, naja, sie sehen sich dann noch nicht am Ende und da geht noch was, so auch nach dem Motto, naja, also wenn jetzt irgendwie das Kartellrecht dagegen spricht, dass wir die von uns erhobenen Forderungen so durchgesetzt bekommen, na, da kann man doch das Kartellrecht ändern. Das fand ich auch sehr konsequent, ja, also in der Bundesregierung wurde das dann auch gleich irgendwie so, naja, über sowas müsste man ja vielleicht mal nachdenken und so, also es wird da auch immer noch über jedes Stückchen gesprungen, was so aus Verlagseite da hingelegt wird. Das finde ich auch wirklich absolut bemerkenswert, ich meine, das ist jetzt keine wilde Debatte gerade um dieses Leistungsschutzrecht wirklich, also zumindest politisch gerade mal nicht so, dass sie jetzt dringend über irgendwelche Verschärfungen oder so weiter unbedingt diskutieren müssten, weil die Wahlen sind ja nun erstmal in ein paar Jahren wieder, das war ja zuletzt dann noch anders und trotz alledem ging es so und dann aber relativ schnell kam dann eben auch schon so die Panik wohl auf bei den Verlagen, die halt Mitglied sind in der VG Media, die aber nicht der Springer Verlag selber sind, weil die sahen natürlich jetzt schon so ihr Schiffchen langsam davon segeln und deswegen haben sie dann eben gesagt, naja, also entweder wir machen das, also erstmal gab es ja diese Verlängerung des ursprünglich von Google genannten Datums ab wann sie das machen wollen, ich habe es jetzt gerade nicht Ich hab nicht mehr im Kopf, wann das war. Das ist irgendwie 9. Oktober sollte es eigentlich sein. Ich guck gerne auf die Seite und da war dann immer noch irgendwie alles in Lang. Und da gab es wohl schon mal so ein erstes Signal mit gibt uns noch mal ein bisschen Zeit. Offensichtlich war die Diskussion innerhalb von VG Media schon etwas erhitzt. Würde ich mal so, also würde mich jetzt nicht überraschen, wenn dem so gewesen sein sollte. Und dann pünktlich zu diesem verlängerten Datum kam es dann halt eben zu dieser Gratis-Einwilligung, was ein super Wort ist. Also die widerrufliche Gratis-Einwilligung. Die im Prinzip einfach sagt so, naja, ihr dürft jetzt trotzdem das tun, was auch alle anderen Verlage, die in der VG Media nicht organisiert sind, schon lange getan haben, nämlich hier, da habt ihr die Lizenz, kostet nichts, macht einfach, Hauptsache wir kriegen noch die Klicks. Und da zeigt sich halt eigentlich auch, auf was für wackeligen Beinen diese ganze Initiative steht.
Na ja, also das Ding war ja in dem Moment, wo das Kartellamt gesagt hat, bitte lasst uns jetzt in Ruhe, sonst untersuchen wir mal, ob ihr nicht ein Kartell seid. Damit war das Thema ja erledigt. Was nicht erledigt ist, ist, dass sie ja nach wie vor jetzt diesen Flurschaden angerichtet haben für kleinere Anbieter. Also denk mal an sowas wie River, denk mal an sowas wie diese kleinen Suchmaschinen, irgendwie T-Online-Startseite oder was auch immer, die irgendwie...
Ja, oder auch irgendwelche Startups, die vielleicht nie gegründet wurden, weil sie einfach von vornherein ihr Businessmodell, was sie sich ausgedacht haben, an der Stelle schon gefährdet sahen.
Noch dazu die ganzen Lobbyisten, die sie irgendwie mal beschäftigt haben, um dieses Gesetz irgendwie zu formulieren für unsere Bundesregierung, die es dann so freundlich war zu übernehmen. Also das ist wirklich eine Vollkatastrophe und es findet seinen Höhepunkt in so einem Witz. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, du merkst ja, die geben nicht auf. Da muss halt jetzt noch das Kartellrecht geändert werden und wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie größere Änderungen im bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch oder was auch immer da noch alles kommen muss, damit die endlich ihren Willen da bekommen.
Ja, am Ende steht noch das Grundgesetz im Wege.
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Das könnte man bei der Gelegenheit jetzt 25 Jahre nach dem Mauerfall, ich meine, stand nicht im Grundgesetz drin, dass das nur der Übergang ist. Dann könnte man das noch mal hochschreiben, dass das Grundgesetz eigentlich gar nicht mehr gültig ist und wir ein neues brauchen, wo noch mal reingeschrieben wird, dass die Verlage geschützt werden müssen vor Google oder so. Da wird denen noch was einfallen.
Staatsräson.
Staatsräson, naja, im Netz gab es natürlich dann viele Witze darüber, dass sie all möglichen Mist wurden und wiederrufliche Gratis-Einwilligungen erteilt, dass sie das nicht selber merken. Aber die merken es ja selber, das haben wir ja gehört bei diesem Interview mit der VG Media Sprecherin. Die merken das ja selber.
Eigentlich wissen sie es ja.
Aber wer es nicht gemerkt hat, ist Spanien. Spanien hat jetzt irgendwie eine Urheberrechtsreform verabschiedet, wo es unter anderem irgendwie darum geht, das ist jetzt nur als Randnotizian, wo es irgendwie darum geht, illegale Downloads dann irgendwie teurer zu bestrafen. Und es soll eine Google-Gebühr geben, die für die Verwendung von Texten Suchmaschinen zur Kasse bitten wird. Das heißt, die haben letztendlich genau dieses Konzept Leistungsschutzrecht ab 2015, im 1. Januar. Geld strafen bis zu 600.000 Euro für Anbieter von digitalen Downloads, schärfere Überwachung zum Schutz des geistigen Eigentums und eben Leistungsschutzrecht.
Also von illegalen Downloads, nicht von Downloads an sich, ne?
Jaja, von illegalen Downloads, habe ich das weggelassen?
Ja, digital.
Okay, sorry. Entschuldigung. Sie haben jetzt also auch ein Leistungsschutzrecht. Also das ist ja auch so ein Erfolgsmodell, das kann man ja jetzt auch schnell exportieren. Gerade nach Spanien, die ja nicht schon genug unter Deutschland... Ah, lassen wir das alles, lassen wir das. Also freuen wir uns, freuen wir uns, lachen wir mit. Es ist doch schön, dass die Politik für uns auch immer noch mal was Amüsantes bereithält, wo man dann auch wirklich mal wieder drüber lachen kann. Das ist so ein bisschen Netzpolitik wie vor 10 Jahren. Das war immer noch, da ging es am Ende, ist da keiner zu, keiner wirklich unter die Räder gekommen, alle konnten gut lachen.
Ich gucke gerade noch mal bei newsgoogle.de, mittlerweile müsste das ja eigentlich alles durch sein, aber tatsächlich, ich sehe jetzt hier irgendwie welt.de, also wir müssen das noch mal korrigieren.
Ja, der Springer-Verlag hat nur Teile seines Angebotes.
Genau, und zwar die Welt, Auto, Autozartung, Sport, ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, ein Computer-Bild, aber nicht bild.de.
Genau, bild.de kommst du auch über Google drauf und ich glaube, wenn du den Direktlink zu Bild suchst, dann ist da glaube ich eine Paywall oder sowas, kann das sein?
Ich weiß nicht, ich klicke so selten auf solche Bild-Links, aber tatsächlich, Computer-Bild ist hier wirklich nur ein normaler Titel und den Rest finde ich jetzt gerade auch gar nichts. Da müsste man sich noch mal ein bisschen genauer anschauen, aber offensichtlich ist das jetzt in Kraft und die anderen Zeitungen werden sich da die Hände gerieben haben.
Ja, man kriegt beim Bild auch, man kommt auch so auf Bild, da ist auch keine Paywall drauf, da habe ich Quatsch gerät. Aber es wäre natürlich gut, wenn da eine vor wäre. Aber um die schlafen Pinal-Empfeilungen, dass die Seite kommt, jetzt nächstes Thema ist.
Kommen wir zur Gesetzgebung, wo etwas länger darüber nachgedacht wurde.
Ja, das war sehr überlegt.
Also es geht um Ungarn, ein Land, was ich persönlich für den größten Problemfall der Europäischen Union halte und leider auch etwas entsetzt bin, dass das nicht auch in der Europäischen Union so behandelt wird. In Ungarn, das ist ja nun wirklich keine Neuigkeit, stehen die Grundrechte und zwar alle möglichen Grundrechte schon seit vielen Jahren eigentlich auf der Abschussliste von dem, was ist der offizielle Titel? Ist er Präsident, ist er Ministerpräsident? Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall Chef der Regierung, Herrn Orban. Dort ist die Opposition mundtot gemacht worden, da ist Wahlrecht geändert worden, Besetzung von Richterposten. Also auf allen Ebenen wurde in Ungarn eine extrem bedenkliche Überarbeitung des Staates vorgenommen, die im Prinzip Wiederwahl des herrschenden Regimes sicherstellen soll und jegliche Opposition im Prinzip verbannt. Das führt auch zur Landflucht, das führt zu so einigen unangenehmen Folgen. Und sie sind sich auch nicht zu faul, da mit ihrem populistischen Ansatz da auch am laufenden Meter wieder neue Korken knallen zu lassen.
Ministerpräsident ist das und man könnte echt, glaube ich, ja, das ist ein Faschist, oder? Also so ein autoritärer Nationalist, das ist, glaube ich, das, was man Faschist nennt.
Kann man so nennen, er hat ja auch selber zu stehen gegeben, dass er ja auch so grundsätzlich sich sehr viel lieber so an Russland als Staatsmodell orientieren würde. Das fand er eigentlich irgendwie ganz überzeugend, wie es da gerade läuft. Na ja, da weiß man dann, glaube ich, auch schon, was man davon halten soll. Na ja, auf jeden Fall schien so der Internetbereich da noch nicht so richtig im Fokus gewesen zu sein. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie es da mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wie es da mit Überwachung an sich aussieht. Da sind sie... Also ich weiß nicht, wie es offiziell damit aussieht, wie es inoffiziell aussieht, das können wir uns, glaube ich, ganz gut vorstellen. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall sickerte jetzt eine neue Planung durch. Das war so vor zwei Wochen, dass man doch jetzt bitte auch mal eine neue Internetsteuer erheben wollen möchte und zwar auf den Traffic, den man verbraucht. Das ist wirklich das Absurdeste an dieser ganzen Forderung.
Naja, ne, ne, ne, Moment. Der Traffic sollte auf den Internetprovider gehen. Also auf den Traffic, den der Internetprovider verbraucht. Aber dem Internetprovider war ausdrücklich nicht verboten, diese Kosten auf seine Kunden umzulegen. Also mit anderen Worten, klar, am Ende werden die Kosten bei den Kunden gelandet.
Ja, natürlich, wie soll es denn denn das sein?
Ist übrigens immer so, aber das wissen ja die Leute nicht. Wenn was billiger wird, dann landet das nicht bei den Kunden und wenn was teurer wird, dann landet es bei den Kunden. 150 forint, das ist knapp 50 Cent, sollte die Steuer betragen, pro Gigabyte.
Wobei man mal wieder unklar ist, in welche Richtung eigentlich und ob es nicht vielleicht sogar in beide Richtungen gehen soll und ob sich das dann gegeneinander wieder aufrechnet. Also es ist überhaupt auch glaube ich sehr unklar und die Regierung hatte vor allem das Problem, dass das wohl ziemlich früh geliegt wurde und es dann eine eine extreme Kakophonie gab aus dem Regierungslager und gar keine klare Linie, was denn nun da eigentlich wirklich geplant sei, mit welcher Intention auch immer. Es gab dann natürlich so Argumentationen wie naja wir wollen ja hier irgendwie verhindern, dass das Geld das Land verlässt und so weiter. Bin ich so ganz so sicher, wem die Provider in Ungarn so gehören und ob das so das Problem ist, dass da quasi Gewinne im Wesentlichen bei ausländischen Unternehmen landen. Das mag ja alles so sein.
Wenn du anfängst den Traffic zu besteuern, dann landen die Gewinne auf jeden Fall überall außerhalb deines Landes. Weil kein Unternehmen wird ja jemals mehr wieder dahin gehen. Also du hast ja automatisch alle Internet-Unternehmen werden dieses Land verlassen.
Das kann gut sein. Vielleicht ist das ja auch so ein Ziel, dass man sozusagen noch das Internet-Unternehmen der eigenen Wahl, nämlich was weiß ich, die lokale Telekom sozusagen mit der Internetversorgung beauftragen möchte, die dann eben auch entsprechend mitspielt und die entsprechenden technischen Maßnahmen auch sicherstellt, die so eine Regierung gerne hätte.
Schön fand ich, sie planten, dass sie dadurch 65 Millionen Euro einnehmen würden. Ich dachte so, 65 Millionen Euro, wenn du 50 Cent pro Gigabyte kriegst, dann heißt das ja, dass du einen Landes-Datentraffic von 130.000 Terabyte hast, oder? Wenn ich jetzt nicht falsch rechne.
Das habe ich jetzt mal eben im Kopf überschlagen.
65 mal 2 und dann Gigabyte-Terabyte müssen 130.000 Terabyte sein. Das wäre ein bisschen wenig, oder?
Ja, ja. 130 Terabyte oder 130 Millionen Terabyte?
130.000 Terabyte. Jetzt rechnen wir bestimmt wieder falsch und ich tu hier noch groß rum, dass man das einfach im Kopf rechnen kann.
Willkommen in dem Abschnitt, den wir später mal rausstellen werden.
Aber ich glaube, dass Sie sich da verrechnet haben und ich würde davon ausgehen, dass Ungarn sehr viel mehr Terabytes umsetzt als irgendwie so wenig. Also 65 Millionen Euro kann doch einfach nicht sein, wenn du pro Gigabyte was in dem Land verbraten wird, irgendwie 50 Cent bekommst, dafür kriegst du doch sehr, sehr viel mehr.
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr unklug, ausgerechnet auf Traffic eine Steuer zu erheben. Also die Idee an sich finde ich ja schon mal wirklich bemerkenswert. Also auf so etwas Doofes ist ja noch nicht mal die Bundesregierung gekommen.
Ja, es ist völlig dämlich. Also die Folgen davon sind halt, also es ist auch so eine fürchterliche Besteuerung, du ausgerechnet kulturelle Teilhabe zu besteuern. Also das ist halt, das wird halt so dazu führen, dass das würde halt katastrophale Konsequenzen haben. Also was das für die Menschen bedeuten würde, dass sie ihnen das, als wenn es sich schon schlimm genug wäre, dass man sich kaum irgendwie auf dem mobilen Telefon Internet leisten kann. Zuhause geht es ja zum Glück noch irgendwie, dass man wenigstens irgendwie einen günstigen Tarif kriegt. Der ist dann zwar nicht schnell, aber man kann als nicht so besonders finanziell betuchte Person irgendwie noch dafür sorgen, dass man so viel Internet haben kann, wie man braucht. Und das ist halt mit so einer Besteuerung dann halt nicht mehr möglich. Es gründete sich ja dann auch sehr schnell oder zumindest in Gefahr. Es gründete sich dann eine Facebook-Gruppe, die innerhalb von fünf Tagen irgendwie fast eine Viertelmillion Mitglieder bekam. Es gab wilde Proteste und das fand ich sehr schön. Habe ich von André geschickt bekommen, den Link. So eine ungarische Seite. Klickt mal auf den Link, der da in dem Pad ist. Die haben ja dann nämlich demonstriert, indem sie alte Computerteile da irgendwie gegen so ein Gebäude geworfen haben.
Ja, CRT-Monitore, die Kartenstrahlmonitore. Braucht ja eh keiner mehr. Eigentlich 1A-Entsorgungsmodell an der Stelle. Ja, sehr schön auch plakativ die Demonstration, die sich da sehr schnell gebildet hat. Also das interessante ist ja eigentlich darum, dass die so erfolgsverwöhnte, was heißt eigentlich diese Partei von ihm, das weiß ich gar nicht, Fiskas oder so was. Ja genau, diese Orban-Partei, dass die halt offensichtlich vollkommen unterschätzt hat, was das wiederum für eine Wirkung haben würde. Weil wir haben ja diesen typischen Effekt, so ein rein digitales Thema und die Leute, die vielleicht bisher das eine oder andere noch immer irgendwie mitgezogen haben und im Netz hat sich dann der Protest sehr schnell formiert und da gibt es ja, sagen wir mal, schon genug Aufregung aus den letzten Jahren, die sich dann da entladen hat und es wurde halt sehr schnell eben auch so ein Anti-Orban-Protest. Und das muss man eben lassen. Sowas erkennt er dann halt relativ schnell und hat dann auch die Leute fix wieder zurückgepfiffen. Der aktuelle Stand der Dinge ist halt, dass er sozusagen der Meinung ist, naja, also erst haben sie die Abstimmung verschoben, das hat aber nicht gewirkt und dann ist er hinterhergekommen und haben gesagt, naja, das sei ja, also es würde jetzt erstmal nicht darüber befunden werden, weil ja die Debatte sei ja, ich weiß nicht genau wie die Formulierung war, aber die Debatte, die Masse wäre jetzt debattenunfähig. Man könnte das ja jetzt gar nicht mehr diskutieren, weil ja da so viel Fehlinformation umherstreifen würde und deswegen, aber er ließ quasi auch schon durchblicken, dass das Thema damit nicht, noch nicht erschlagen ist.
Ach echt?
Nein, nein, also das ist zumindest so ein bisschen die Einschätzung der politischen Beobachter, die ich gelesen habe, dass das eben bei ihm auch eine beliebte Strategie ist. Solche aufkeimenden Widerstände erst mal so ein bisschen ins Leere zu laufen, so nach dem Motto, naja, dann machen wir damit erst mal gar nichts. Und wenn dann eben der richtige Moment gekommen ist, wenn man ausgemacht hat, was so die eigentlichen feuerschlagenden Details waren, dann wird es eben über eine andere Art und Weise nochmal rübergezogen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das Thema schon komplett durch ist. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das jetzt schon irgendwie eine vollkommene Niederlage gewesen ist. Das war eher so ein kleiner Tanzfehler, aber der Walzer ist noch lange nicht beendet.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine ganz gute Strategie, die wir auch in Deutschland sehen, die da immer ganz gut fruchtet. Du lässt die mal alle sich totlaufen, lasst die mal ihren Proteststurm durchbringen und dann verschieben wir die Debatte einfach so lange und ein Dreivierteljahr später kriegst du für das gleiche Thema noch sehr viel weniger Leute auf die Straße. Dieser Empörungsmoment bei großen Demonstrationen ist tatsächlich etwas, was du immer nur einmal hinkriegst.
Genau, und mittlerweile waren dann, nach dieser Verlautbarung, liefen dann eben auch nur noch so ein paar Hunderter rum. Und das war dann, sagen wir mal, auch erst mal der entsprechende Wunsch an der Stelle. Tja, das werden wir vielleicht noch mal aufgreifen müssen. Ich warte ja nur darauf, bis hier jemand auf so eine Idee kommt, aber ich glaube, das würde hier sehr schnell niedergebügelt werden. Also der Preis ist ja auch so dermaßen jenseits von Gut und Böse. Ich meine, wenn man sich so die realen ISP-Kosten anschaut, die so im Interconnect so ein Gigabyte kostet, das ist ja mittlerweile keine Größe mehr. Also 50 Cent, das ist ja ein absurder Preis.
Also in Deutschland würdest du ja nicht eine Besteuerung von Traffic allgemein bekommen, sondern in Deutschland würdest du eine Besteuerung von Traffic außerhalb Deutschlands und außerhalb der Europäischen Union bekommen. Das wäre so das, was so kann ich mir jetzt in Deutschland vorstellen.
Ach so, du meinst, dass die Ausländer dann sozusagen für unsere Daten, weil die benutzen ja unsere Datenautobahnen.
Genau, wenn du mit der Datenautobahn weiter wegfährst, wenn du zum Google gehst und nicht zur web.de Startseite, ja, dann musst du halt für bezahlen. Kerosinzuschlag, gar keine Frage. Kannst du auch nicht einfach irgendwie, weißt du? Also so, guck mal, und schon macht das irgendwie total Sinn, weil sowas kannst du dir nämlich vorstellen. Sowas kann man sich in Deutschland wieder vorstellen. Und da kann man nämlich noch beknackter, da kann man noch viel, viel lustigere, verrückter Sachen machen. Und ich kann dir eins sagen, mein lieber Tim. Menschen, die das freie Internet erlebt haben und in meinem Alter sind, die müssen sich schon ganz anstrengen, ganz schön anstrengen, um die CDU zu akzeptieren. Aber wir sind eine Demokratie. Wir respektieren die Wahlentscheidung der Menschen und fragen uns gleichzeitig, ist die Partei, die da Kanzlerin und Minister stellt, tatsächlich schon so weit weg von den Vorstellungen, die NSA und BND haben, bei der Unterdrückung der Menschen hier, dass wir ihr voll vertrauen können? Und es gibt Teile in dieser Partei, wo ich, wie viele andere auch, Probleme habe, dieses Vertrauen zu entwickeln. Und wir erleben gerade in Deutschland einen heftigen Meinungsstreit. Ja, was ist denn diese Partei nun wirklich? Ja Tim, und du hast heute nicht die Nachrichten gelesen. Das ist schlecht. Das ist schlecht, ich habe gerade Nachrichten gelesen, das bringe ich unter. Das war Joachim Gauck. Allerdings nicht über die CDU, sondern über die Linkspartei. Okay, nächstes Thema. Ich wollte das noch unbedingt loswerden.
Sehr schön.
Also EUGH, der EUGH hat geurteilt, das ist ein Urteil, darauf haben wir auch lange gewartet. Nur um unser Bizarrometer noch mal zu kalibrieren, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, in Ungarn, das ist schon sehr bizarr. Der EUGH musste mal eben urteilen, dass YouTube-Videos einmelden, keine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist. Das war eine interessante Gerichtsverhandlung, die da stattgefunden hat. Es ging um einen zwei Minuten langen Werbefilm eines Wasserfilter-Herstellers, der von Dritten auf YouTube eingestellt worden war. Der Wasserfilter-Hersteller klagte jetzt gegen Handelsvertreter, die für die Konkurrenz von diesem Wasserfilter-Hersteller gearbeitet haben und aber dieses Video auf ihrer Seite eingebettet hatten. Der hat ihn dann geschrieben, ihr arbeitet für die Konkurrenz, ihr dürft dieses Video von uns nicht einbetten. Und ich glaube, er hat sich aber darauf berufen, so muss es wohl sein, sonst wäre es ja keine Frage des Urheberrechtes, auf das Urheberrecht, dass sie nämlich an diesem Wasserfilter-Werbe-Video hatten, was sie eben aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht auf der Seite dieser konkurrierenden Handelsvertreter haben wollten.
Aber sehr wohl auf YouTube online gestellt haben.
Nee, wenn ich das richtig lese, hatte das auch jemand anders auf YouTube online gestellt, nicht diese Handelsvertreter und auch nicht sie selber.
Was war denn der Grund, warum die das überhaupt online gestellt haben? Also was war der Grund, warum die das da embeddet haben? Weil es so schlecht war oder?
Es ging da jetzt nicht draus hervor, aber ich vermute mal, dass sie dann irgendwie sagen, hier, das ist ein schlechtes Gerät. Oder darunter geschrieben haben folgende Behauptungen, es stimmt nicht oder unser Gerät ist besser. Aber das geht da jetzt nicht wirklich draus hervor. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das dann auf EU-Ebene ist, mit unlauterem Wettbewerb und sowas alles, aber vergleichende Werbung oder was auch immer. Aber sie sind eben über Urheberrecht gekommen, das heißt, sie werden irgendeinen Grund gehabt haben, warum sie es nicht mochten, dass dieses Video da war. Und dann haben sie halt es offensichtlich über so eine klassische Urheberrechtsabmahnung gemacht. Die Beklagten haben dann die Unterlassungserklärung abgegeben, aber wollten nicht die Abmahnkosten zahlen. Also ging das dann irgendwie vor die deutschen Gerichte und dann landete das vom Bundesgerichtshof und der hatte das Verfahren ausgesetzt, also war in Deutschland und hatte das Verfahren ausgesetzt, um vom EuGH klären zu lassen, ob es sich bei dem Einbetten dieses Videos nicht vielleicht doch um eine öffentliche Wiedergabe handelt. Weil das ist ja immer das Problem bei solchen, bei das Urheberrecht gilt ja erst ab einer öffentlichen Wiedergabe. Oder bei Videos, wenn ich da das Urheberrecht wirklich verletze, als jemand der sich das anschaut, dann bin ich ja nur quasi für den einen Schaden, den ich selber verursacht habe. Also schlimmstenfalls sagen wir mal ein Kino-Ticket oder sowas. Das ist der Schaden, den ich als Zuschauer dieses Videos verursacht habe, indem ich mich an dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung beteiligt habe. Derjenige, der es zugänglich gemacht hat, der macht sich aber natürlich um einiges mehr strafbar. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Kino eröffne und darin raubkopierte Filme zeige und eine öffentliche Wiedergabe mache, dann verletze ich natürlich dieses Urheberrecht schlimmer. Und das wäre dann der Fall gewesen bei dem Framing, also bei dem Einbetten eines YouTube-Videos. Und das wollten sie jetzt klären lassen vom EUGH. Denn, und so haben sie argumentiert, oder das war die Frage, durch dieses Framing ermöglicht es dem, durch dieses Framing erscheint es ja auf deiner eigenen Webseite. Und damit wollten sie halt argumentieren, dadurch machst du es dir natürlich auch zu eigen. Aber gleichzeitig musst du es ja dafür nicht. Kopieren. Nur durchs Kopieren würde es tatsächlich dann halt dem Urheberrecht unterliegen. Und der EuGH hat dann geurteilt, ja, okay, dadurch, dass du das Video einbettest, das YouTube-Video in deine Webseite, wird kein neues Publikum erschlossen, was nicht ohnehin schon da wäre, weil das Video ja bereits für alle Internetnutzer zugänglich war. Also ist das Einbetten kein Verstoß gegen das Urheberrecht.
Wie schön, da haben wir ja mal wieder etwas geklärt, was uns intuitiv schon immer irgendwie klar gewesen ist. Ich frage mich nur, wo dieser Begriff Framing auf einmal herkommt.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, der Begriff, das habe ich so von dem bei Heise so gelesen. Ich glaube aber, dass man inzwischen wird das doch, sind das keine iFrames?
Doch, doch, doch.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Es ist ein Frame, von Framing war bisher nie die Rede.
Ja, Framing ist auch, glaube ich, was anderes. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das auf so einer Ebene dann embedding, Framing, ich meine, wahrscheinlich haben die sich fest, haben die gesehen, die restliche Seite ist wie ein Rahmen, um das YouTube-Video herum, es handelt sich um Framing. Na ja, aber ok, also die eingebetteten Videos verstoßen nicht gegen das Urheberrecht. Das ist interessant für unser nächstes Thema. Ja, so schnell kann das gehen.
Was war denn noch gleich unser nächstes Thema?
Unser nächstes Thema ist KinoX.to.
Ja, das sind ja auch so richtige Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Das sind Urheberrechtsverletzter. Und zwar gab es eine Anzeige der GVU, der Gesellschaft zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen, gegen die Betreiber der Webseite KinoX.to. Wir erinnern uns irgendwann, das war wahrscheinlich 2010 oder so was, gab es eine dicke Razzia bei Kino.to. Und die sind da irgendwie alle relativ stark einige Zeit später zu, ich glaube, viereinhalb Jahren Haft verurteilt worden. Die hatten nämlich die Seite Kino.to betrieben, auf der es eben immer Links gab zu irgendwelchen Shared-Hoster und Video-Einbettern, wo man dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, Filme oder Fernsehserien schauen konnte. Und dieses Kino.to-Modell hatte deshalb sich größerer Beliebtheit erfreut, weil die Nutzer offenbar nicht so viel Wert auf die Bildqualität legen, sondern natürlich auch darauf, ihren eigenen Arsch zu schützen vor der strafrechtlichen Verfolgung. Und wenn du jetzt so ein eingebettetes Video schaust, dann ist so die juristisch höchste, theoretisch denkbare Strafe, die du dafür bekommen kannst, Anwaltsgebühren, die jetzt irgendwie bei 155 Euro gedeckt sind, plus den Schaden, den du angerichtet hast. Das wären also so, was weiß ich, 10 Euro oder so. Bei Torrens ist das ja aber viel höher, die Strafe, die du bekommen kannst, weil du dich ja gleichzeitig an der Verbreitung beteiligst. Das ist also der juristische Unterschied. Gleichzeitig erinnern wir uns an die ganzen Red-Tube-Sachen. Bei denen ist ja dann am Ende für die Stream-Shower ebenfalls keine Straferfolgung gab. Das heißt, solche Streams zu schauen, ist im Moment noch mit einem relativ geringen Risiko verbunden, dafür tatsächlich einmal großartige Strafen zu bekommen im Moment. Nachdem dieses Kino-TO plattgemacht wurde, dauerte es nur ein paar Tage und es gab dann KinoX.to. Das ist übrigens auf netzpolitik.org noch einer der meistgeklickten Artikel überhaupt und auch mein meistgeklickter. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass als letztes Mal zum Zehnjährigen noch ein paar Statistiken gemacht wurden, dass er da immer noch unter den ersten drei war, wenn nicht sogar der meistgelesene. Aus KinoTO wird KinoX.to. Denn nachdem dieses KinoTO-Hops genommen wurde, dauerte das irgendwie nur ein, zwei Tage. Dann gab es halt KinoX.to und die machten frohlich mit dem gleichen Ding weiter. So, und da hat jetzt die GVU eben eine Anzeige erstattet, sicherlich schon vor langer Zeit. Und es gab jetzt dann eine Großrazier der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Dresden, die nämlich den Betreibern gewerbsmäßige Urheberrechtsverletzungen, Steuerhinterziehung, räuberische Erpressung und Brandstiftung unterstellte.
Genau, das ist auch eine Brandstiftung.
Ja, die haben sich wohl mit anderen Urheberrechtskriminellen irgendwie schlecht verstanden und die dann irgendwie auch bedroht und irgendwie mal ein Auto angezündet oder so was, ja. Und es ging um zwei Brüder im Alter von 25 und 21 Jahren, die die Polizei aber nicht im Haus ihrer Eltern in der Nähe von Lübeck angetroffen hat und jetzt zur europaweiten Fahnung ausgeschrieben hat. Kino XTO ist weiterhin online, denn der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft fehlt nach eigenen Angaben die Zugangsdaten, um das Ding offline zu nehmen.
Was?
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich habe mir jetzt nicht die Mühe gemacht, zu schauen, wo diese Seite gehostet ist. Also TO ist ja von welcher? Tonga, ja. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die ihren Server in einem anderen Land stehen haben, aber ich gehe mal nicht davon aus, dass der in Deutschland steht. Also müsste man jetzt mal noch mal recherchieren. Hab ich nicht gemacht, gehe ich ganz ehrlich zu. Die haben jetzt bei den Jungs irgendwie das Elternhaus geradet und die Jungs sind halt irgendwie, man weiß nicht, wo die sind, irgendwo im Ausland, hatten sich wohl schon vor ein paar Monaten aus dem Staub gemacht.
Also ich hab mal ein kleines Trace-Route gestartet, auf die IP-Adresse, die da rausgegeben wird. Es läuft da wohl gerade kein Dienst drauf, aber es versickert irgendwo in Punkt RU, also Ausland.
Ja, das ist eine ganz gute Idee, dass da irgendwie, da ist man halbwegs gut aufgehoben. Und jetzt haben die die Seite noch nicht mal runter, ja? Also die Jungs sind irgendwie über alle Berge schon vor Monaten abgehauen und die Staatsanwaltschaft schafft es noch nicht mal, diese Seite abzuschalten. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, also die Server laufen, so war jetzt irgendwie der Stand weiterhin. Die Spekulation ist natürlich jetzt, ob die Staatsanwaltschaft die nicht vielleicht einfach anlässt als Honeypots, um eben die Menschen, die darauf zugreifen, jetzt irgendwie zu loggen und die irgendwie einer Strafe zuzuführen. Aber Siehe RedTube urteilt, dass über das wir ja auch damals ausführlich gesprochen haben, wo es um diese Porno-Abmahnungen ging, Streaming ist eigentlich nicht illegal und maximal könnte man da halt irgendwie unter sehr großzügiger Auslegung des Urheberrechts irgendwie eine Anwaltsabmahngeburt und ein bisschen Schaden rausprügeln. Wert zu legen ist aber auf die Feststellung, dass das, was die Jungs da machen, tatsächlich nicht in Ordnung ist, oder was Kino.to auch gemacht hat, denn die haben ja nicht nur die Seite betrieben, die diese Links zur Verfügung stellt, sondern eben auch die Seiten, wohin die Links dann führen, nämlich diese ganzen Share-Toaster, die ja hauptsächlich mit dem Angebot werben, dass du eine große Datei per E-Mail verschicken kannst. Die haben ja trotzdem dann auch kommerzielle Angebote und für diese wurde dann eben da in diesem Rahmen geworben und über die wurde das Ganze dann auch monetarisiert. Zusätzlich zu den Werbeangeboten, die natürlich dann noch auf der Seite von KinoX gemacht wurden. Das heißt, die haben schon ganz gutes Geld damit verdient und mit diesem Geld, was sie da verdient haben, haben sie dann wiederum andere motiviert, doch mal in Kinos zu gehen und da kleine Aufzeichnungen von den Filmen zu machen oder Filmverleiher oder Kinovorführer dann da irgendwie auf den Pfad der Tugend geholt. Das sind keine Leute, mit denen man sich solidarisieren sollte. Macht auch, glaube ich, gerade keiner.
Ja, die ganze KinoX-Geschichte ist ja auch das, was in Österreich diese Netzsperrendiskussion losgetreten hat. Dazu hat ja Thomas in der letzten Ausgabe auch nochmal berichtet.
Genau. Jemand, der übrigens auch gerade verurteilt wurde, der wurde nicht geratzt, wie man so schön sagt, sondern der sitzt schon oder saß schon seit November 2013 in U-Haft in Dänemark, wohin er ausgeliefert wurde aus seiner Heimat Schweden, ist der gute Gottfried Zwartholm Vark, einer der drei oder vier Mitbegründer von Pirate Bay, dem vorgeworfen wurde, massenhaft Informationen aus den dänischen Kriminalführerschein- und Personenregistern sowie dem Schengen Informationssystem heruntergeladen zu haben. Und das auch noch im Auftrag einer weiteren Person. Die beiden waren jetzt, wie gesagt, vor Gericht und wurden schuldig gesprochen. Ging es um eine Viertelmillion Datensätze. Gottfried hat weiterhin immer betont, dass er das nicht gewesen sei und sein Computer von einer fremden Macht ferngesteuert wurde. Keine Ahnung, was davon zu halten ist. Habe ich mich nicht weiter mit auseinandergesetzt. Aber die wurden jetzt beide schuldig gesprochen. Das Strafmaß wird noch festgelegt.
Ja, es ist eine sehr unangenehme Geschichte. Auch nicht nur jetzt die Verfolgung von Gottfried, sondern natürlich auch von Peter Sunde, der mittlerweile im Knast ist in Schweden. Hoffentlich nicht mehr sehr lange. Ich glaube, ein Jahr hat er abzusitzen. Diese ganze Verfolgung von Pirate Bay trägt schon wirklich eine sehr bedenkliche Gewand. Wir haben das hier irgendwann auch mal thematisiert gehabt.
Wir hatten das damals thematisiert, als er nämlich in Kambodscha auf Wunsch von Schweden verhaftet wurde.
Der Gottfried, ne?
Der Gottfried, ja.
Aber auch der Fall von Peter Sunde ist also wirklich haarsträubend. Im Prinzip ist die Beweislage einfach mehr als dünn gewesen. Man hat ihm eigentlich fast gar nichts nachweisen können. Trotzdem wurde da einfach ein Riesenfall daraus gemacht. Deswegen macht es jetzt sehr schwer, das jetzt so zu glauben. Gerade die Rolle von Dänemark an der Stelle ist mir auch ein bisschen unklar. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt in Schweden zu wenig gegen ihn zusammenbekommen haben. Oder warum überhaupt Schweden sich da veranlasst, ihn nach Dänemark auszuweisen und zu überliefern. Er ist ja schwedischer Staatsbürger, ich nichts verpasst habe.
Jaja, der wurde auch in Schweden wegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu einer einjährigen Haftstrafe verurteilt. Genauso wie Peter Sunde.
Jetzt natürlich die Frage, was dabei rauskommt. Strafmaß wird noch festgelegt, weißt du irgendwie wann?
Bis zu 5 Jahre, wann weiß ich nicht. Aber man rechnet wohl so mit 5 Jahren. Also ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, was, also ich kenne die Hintergründe dann nicht, warum es da jetzt genau geht und wie realistisch das ist. Dass er das war oder nicht, kann ich sowieso nicht beurteilen. Es ist aber erstaunlich, mit welcher Vehemenz den Leuten dann nachgegangen wird. Wir hatten das ja auch ausführlich besprochen damals, als Peter verurteilt wurde und als sie ihn dann irgendwann eingesperrt haben. Dass dieses Verfahren irgendwie auf haarsträubende Weise unfair und unsauber war. Ob das jetzt auf Gottfried ebenso zutrifft, kann ich an der Stelle nicht sagen. Ich hab nur die Meldung mitbekommen und warf. Hab mir gedacht, ach guck, jemand der sagt, er war es nicht für eine relativ komischen Hack auf einmal verurteilt. So schnell kann es gehen. Die lassen sich so schnell nicht in Ruhe.
Ja, kommen wir zu ähnlich verstörenden Diskussionen diesmal aus den USA. Hier ist eigentlich jetzt nicht wirklich was passiert, aber ich dachte mal, ich heb das mal trotzdem so ein bisschen hier als Thema auf, als eine ganz interessante Entwicklung begleitet. Was ist passiert? Es gab irgendwie öffentliche Äußerungen von FBI-Chef James Comey, der sich dazu äußerte zu den frisch angekündigten Verschlüsselungsplänen von Apple und Google, die sich im Wesentlichen auf ihre Mobilfunk-OS, also iOS und Android bezogen, dass sie jetzt mit dem neuen Release von iOS 8 bzw. von dem kommenden Release von Android 5, dass jetzt diese Unternehmen alles nur irgendwie Erdenkliche in Anstrengung bringen wollen, um ein einfaches Eindringen auch von der Polizei in diese Inhalte der Telefone, wenn man in einem solchen Telefon habhaft wird, irgendwie zu unterbinden, durch ausführliche, topaktuelle, wohlgeprüfte Kryptographie. Das Ganze muss sich als solches auch überhaupt erst mal beweisen. Ich meine, die Tatsache, dass es bei iOS 8 jetzt auch schon wieder einen Jailbreak gab, etc. und dass die letzten Jahre eigentlich immer gezeigt haben, dass es ja dann doch immer irgendwie wieder einen Weg reingibt, eben zur Not eben auch über Sicherheitslücken, kann einen schon mal grundsätzlich natürlich daran zweifeln lassen, dass so etwas am Ende auch wirklich zuverlässig funktioniert, insbesondere wenn man weiß, dass NSA und eben auch wahrscheinlich andere Behörden wie FBI sich eben auch selber auf dem Schwarzmarkt gerne bedienen, um solche bekannt geworden oder noch nicht bekannt gewordenen Sicherheitslücken dann gegebenenfalls auch aufzukaufen, um sie dann in eigener Software zu nutzen. Trotz alledem finde ich das an sich schon mal recht bemerkenswert, dass das jetzt von diesen Unternehmen so postuliert wird. Jetzt kann man ihnen natürlich Glauben schenken oder nicht. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon drüber diskutiert und meintest so, naja, das kann ja jetzt auch die große Scharade sein, dass man hier so ein bisschen Ping-Pong spielt. Was ist jetzt überhaupt erstmal passiert? Also der FBI-Chef hat sich dazu geäußert und meinte, naja, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass jetzt hier der Polizei einfach der Zugriff auf diese Telefone so entzogen wird, indem jetzt auf einmal tatsächlich funktionierende Verschlüsselung zum Einsatz kommt. Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Ja, so würden ja Mordfälle ungelöst bleiben, Verdächtige freikommen und Gerechtigkeit würde ja verhindert werden. Also klassische Terror-Paare an der Stelle auch wieder ein bisschen erweitert auf allgemeine Kriminalität. Und wo kämen wir denn da hin? Und forderte einen sogenannten Front-Door-Zugriff auf diese Telefone. Was ich insofern eine sehr pfiffige Formulierung fand, weil das, was er so als Front-Door bezeichnet, das würden wir halt eher eigentlich als Back-Door bezeichnen. Nein, es ging hier nicht um Back-Doors, es ging hier um Front-Doors. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann in irgendeiner Form weniger anrüchtig klingen sollte oder so, vermutlich. So oder so ist das die Forderung an Hersteller, Hintertürchen, die eben durch das FBI und andere Organisationen dann legal gedutzt werden können bzw. ohne eben diesen Security-Aufwand treiben zu müssen, den ich vorhin schon gesagt hatte. Warum finde ich das überhaupt erwähnenswert? Das Ganze ist insofern erwähnenswert, als dass jetzt hier quasi ein neuer Krieg um Verschlüsselung entsteht. Also auf einmal kommen die Behörden und sagen, na ja, es kann ja wohl nicht angehen, dass die Verschlüsselung auf einmal so gut ist, dass wir da nicht mehr durchkommen. Also das kann alles wie gesagt eine Scharade sein, es kann aber auch sein, dass sie tatsächlich beunruhigt sind an der Stelle. Und oh Gott, oh Gott, nach der ganzen Snowden-Diskussion rüsten jetzt die großen Unternehmen auf und sehen uns auch als Feind. Ich meine, wenn man den öffentlichen Äußerungen folgt, kann man dann sehr wohl diesen Eindruck gewinnen. Also Apple zumindest hat sich da ja relativ klar positioniert und gesagt, na ja, so hier, in euer Telefon soll halt niemand reinkommen, kein Krimineller und auch keine Polizei. So, das haben die ja so gesagt. Und das ist insofern schon mal eine ganz wagemutige Äußerung, finde ich, für Amerikaner, die ja dann sonst immer eigentlich immer massiv staatstreu unterwegs sind, zumindest in ihren Formulierungen, mitunter dann halt auch in ihren Handlungen. Und das eben überhaupt erst mal so formulieren. Ich glaube, Google war da nicht ganz so explisit oder ich habe es zumindest nicht so gut mitbekommen. Immerhin haben sie sich dann aber eben auch diesen Aussagen angeschlossen und gesagt, dass es für sie eben sehr wohl auch ein Ziel wäre. Ich habe das mal so CryptoWars 2.0 genannt, weil die CryptoWars gab es ja schon mal. Verschlüsselung war früher auch schon mal von der US-Regierung als was ganz furchtbar Schlimmes und Böses interpretiert worden. Zumindest wenn es die anderen haben. Also natürlich wurde Verschlüsselung sehr früh in den USA vorangetrieben. Also die Entwicklung von Algorithmen etc. natürlich auch die Anwendung bei den Behörden und Geheimdiensten und was weiß ich, Militär vermutlich auch. Aber der Export von Cryptografie ins Ausland war dann halt verboten. Zumindest in Form von Software. Das ist so ein bisschen in die Geschichte eingegangen als die CryptoWars, was ja damals dann pfiffigerweise dadurch zu Fall gebracht wurde, dass Crypto-Aktivisten, die Cypherpunks und andere angefangen haben, dann den Source-Code von PGP auszudrucken, als Buch auszuführen, um es dann in Holland auf dem Hackercamp wieder einzuscannen.
Das war als wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichung glaube ich auch ausgeführt.
Weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie es deklariert war, aber es fiel dann einfach unter freie Meinungsäußerung das grundlegende Recht. Der Bücherexport war von dieser Regelung so nicht gedeckt und Bücher konnten ja dann auch exportiert werden und das auch nie gegen vorgegangen worden und dass man die dann wieder einscannen kann. Die digitale Verbreitung wurde verfolgt, aber auf den Kniff mit den Büchern scheinen sie nicht gekommen zu sein. Das ist so ein bisschen bekannt geworden als die CryptoWars, die im Prinzip insofern gewonnen wurden, als dass dann eben auch diese Restruktion irgendwann wegfielen. Und man auch gesehen hat, okay, es gibt jetzt hier einen Bedarf der USA, auch da kommerziell entsprechend tätig und erfolgreich zu sein und lieber wir machen das jetzt hier in so halbwegs überschaubarer Form und dann kommt das alles von uns und wir installieren quasi die Backdoors bei den anderen, als dass es irgendwie andersrum ist. Und jetzt weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, ich habe das auch nicht zu sehr verfolgt, aber es gab in dem Zusammenhang noch eine andere interessante Meldung, nämlich dass die Firma Wind River Systems, die wohl mittlerweile eine Abteilung von Intel letztlich ist, zu 750.000 US-Dollar Konventionalsstrafe verurteilt wurde, was sie wohl auch irgendwie einfach so hingenommen hat. Das Ganze ging wohl auch eine Selbstanzeige voraus, weil sie ja Software ohne Lizenz, also Exporte quasi, unerlaubte Exporte von Krypto-Software nach China, Hongkong, Russland, Israel, Südafrika, Südkorea und ich glaube auch noch ein paar anderen Ländern durchgeführt haben. Das Ganze habe zwischen 2008 und 2011 stattgefunden und ein Jahr später, also 2012, hat Wintero das irgendwie selbst auch bekannt gegeben. Keine Ahnung, was da nun dahinter gesteckt hat. Mich hat das jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, weil mir das gar nicht bewusst war, dass es solche Restriktionen irgendwie noch gibt.
Tatsächlich. Ich erinnere mich noch an den Netscape-Browser, den ich irgendwie dann nicht mit, den man nur irgendwie mit ich glaube 128 Bit...
56. Nur mit 56 Bit und nicht mit 128 runterladen durfte.
Genau, ja. Genau 256 gab es damals irgendwie offenbar noch nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß ja, das war irgendwie ein Ding, den Netscape-Browser nur mit einer bestimmten Verschlüsselungsstärke oder Schlüssellänge zu haben, weil die Amerikaner den sonst nicht hergeben durften, weil das ein Waffenexport gewesen wäre.
Naja, das ist schön absurd.
Naja, ich meine, sie sind natürlich mit der Strategie, die sie dann später gefahren sind natürlich sehr, sehr viel besser gefahren, zu sagen, okay, wir werden das jetzt nicht verhindern können, dass sich diese, dass sich die Krypto verbreitet, dann lass uns wenigstens zusehen, dass wir irgendwie das, dass das möglichst auf Zertifikatsmodellen basiert, wo wir am Ende uns immer noch mal selber was signieren können, um da den man in the middle zu machen. Also da haben sie ja, die Strategie war ja schon sinnvoller zu sagen, okay, dann machen wir halt erstens die Implementierungen kaputt, zweitens die Sicherheit auf den Endpunkten kaputt und drittens, weiß ich nicht, sorgen wir dafür, dass es ein völlig skurriles, obskures CA-Modell gibt, wo wir genug Möglichkeiten haben, am Ende dann man in the middle zu machen. Also die Strategie war aus deren Perspektive durchaus besser. Du hast das jetzt ja nur so kurz als Charade benannt. Ich meine, es wäre in der Tat natürlich das sinnvollste Handeln für sowohl die US-Regierung bzw. hier ins Ganzen des FBI als auch Apple in einer solchen Situation, wie sie jetzt da ist, wo die Sicherheit, die Vertrauenswürdigkeit dieser Unternehmen in Frage steht, genau so etwas zu machen. Nämlich zu sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt hier wirklich was richtig Sicheres und dann gibt es sogar noch mal zwei, drei kritische Statements vom FBI. Das ist ja schon kein schlechter Outcome, wäre kein schlechter Outcome für beide, wenn es jetzt trotzdem noch einen Weg in diese Geräte gäbe. Das war erst vor kurzem auch noch so eine kleine Randmeldung. Ich will ja eigentlich, ich halte ja Security-Sachen immer hier raus. Aber ich glaube, es war ein deutscher Richter, der entschieden hatte, naja, der Fingerabdruck, den du da hast, den hast du ja, das ist nicht Wissen und das heißt, du kannst sehr wohl dazu gezwungen werden, deinen Finger auf den Fingerabdrucksensor deines Telefones zu legen, um anderen dazu Zugang zu ermöglichen. Im Gegensatz zu deinem Passwort einzugeben, da könnte ich zum Glück Deutsche, da könnte ich nur irgendwie britische Polizeibeamte zu zwingen. Übrigens, das war ein US-Strafverfolger, nicht deutschisch. Also es war ein US-Urteil, kein deutsches. Entschuldigung, habe ich falsch gesagt. Glücklicherweise habe ich jetzt schnell noch den Link geklickt. Deswegen habe ich auch so gestammelt. Ja, schnell noch Blog-Feefe und Suche und Klicke. In Virginia wurde jetzt zum ersten Mal geurteilt, Fingerabdruck ist in Ordnung. Und das geht natürlich dann auch wieder damit einher, dass man sagt, okay, das ist ja sowieso, noch mal kurz auf Kryptographie zurückzukommen. Es gibt einmal diesen Kryptoresearch, der ja irgendwie auch so eher eine Gedankenwettrennen ist. Was schön ist, irgendwie zu sagen, guck mal hier, jetzt haben wir irgendwie, wir haben diesen und jene Schiffre geknackt und wir brauchen nur so und so lange. Und in der Implementierung ist das Ganze um ein paar Bits kaputt, dann kann man das wieder brute force und so weiter. Aber der eigentliche Knackpunkt bei diesem ganzen Kryptogramm ist, ich meine die Algorithmen, die sicheren Algorithmen sind bekannt. Und an denen, oder die als stark geltenden Algorithmen sind bekannt. Und an denen scheint auch jetzt erstmal nichts gerüttelt worden zu sein. Der Teil, der natürlich aber viel kaputt ist, ist eben die Schlüsselerstellung, die Zufallszahlen, Generierungen, die Sicherheit des Gerätes, auf dem das alles gemacht wird. Und insofern wäre ich also vorsichtig oder ruhig, wenn da irgendwie davon die Rede ist, dass jetzt irgendein Gerät auf einmal sicher wäre. Oder dass irgendeine Krypto besonders geil wäre. Und wir uns deshalb keine Sorgen mehr machen müssten.
Ja, sehr viel mehr kann man da jetzt auch erst mal nicht zu sagen, oder?
Ja, und deswegen fand ich, also ich fand diese Debatte jetzt nur so mittelspannend. Also es ist für mich eigentlich deshalb uninteressant, weil ich weder die Behauptungen von Apple noch die vom FBI prüfen kann, noch ihnen trauen kann. Und insofern ist das für mich Rauschen. Rauschenweide. Und es würde auch nicht mein persönliches Sicherheitsgefühl oder Sicherheitsniveau oder meinen Umgang mit diesem Smartphone ändern. Selbst wenn ich es prüfen könnte.
Ja. Naja, schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Machen wir Mucke?
Genau, denn jetzt kommen wir zu unserem beliebten Segment, den Terminen. Ja, und los geht's mit einem Termin, der schon fast schon wieder verstrichen ist. Denn am 30.10. gab es eine Universität Heidelberg, den Staat der Ringvorlesungen, Digitale Gesellschaft, Netzpolitik, Bürgerrechte und die Machtfrage. Den Anfang machte Markus Becke dal, aber ab dem 6.11. ist noch einiges zu holen, denn spätere Referenten werden dabei sein, wie Internet Governance Expertin Jeannette Hoffmann, Datenschützer Peter Schaar, Facebook-Kritiker Maximilian Schrems und viele andere mehr.
Am 12.11.2014 abends in der Heinrich-Pöll-Stiftung in Berlin gibt es eine CryptoParty. Und zwar mit Fiona Krakenburger, bekannt vom Podcast Noobcore, Markus Reuter, Referent der Stiftung und dem IT-Sicherheitsexperten Linus Neumann.
Wer das wohl sein mag, aber wirklich richtig netzpolitisch irrelevant wird es am 22. und 23.11., denn da ist der nächste Podlauf-Podcaster-Workshop. Es sind noch wenige Plätze zu haben.
Das Phänomen des Trollings ist seit Jahrzehnten verbreitet, aber noch erschreckend wenig erforscht. Die reflexive und extensive Beschäftigungsmethodik, welche eine traditionell explodierte Stellung im Kontext der Veranstaltung Trollcon 2014 einnimmt, erlaubt es, das Thema Trolling invasiv zu sensualisieren und führt unausweichlich zu einem ergebnisorientierten Dialog am 29.11.2014 im Raumzeitlabor in Mannheim.
Ja, Linus, das bringt uns an das Ende dieser unterhaltsamen Ausgabe. Aber wie immer, das wird nicht die letzte bleiben. Denn ein bisschen Themen haben wir, glaube ich, noch.
Wir haben Themen rausgeworfen.
Ja, ohne Ende. Weitergeschoben, verschoben, umgeändert, angepasst und gefälscht.
Ja, und nächstes Mal müssen wir wieder darauf achten, dass bei mir nicht schon Nacht ist.
Ja, oder bei mir. Ja, alle, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und wir hören uns bald wieder.